what grade do you give to the entire
approach
to the off-season by a team that was
just in the super bowl two years ago
i mean i i don't even know what grade
like the the
49ers made no sense in the offseason
like this the trey lance pick
it could work out but it also felt like
you
said in the previous segment they were
just trying to make up for past
mistakes i would say a c-minus c-minus
feels about right
and i still think the you know i think
kyle shanahan is one of the best coaches
in the nfl
i think the 49ers still have a roster
that can win games
but it does feel like they're one foot
in one foot out
trey lance needs a little work uh jimmy
garoppolo they have not
let's just say this they have not
exactly uh given jimmy garoppolo
a vote of confidence right so you have a
quarterback now
who it's clear the coaching staff and
the front office don't want to be
playing quarterback
and you have a quarterback who is by all
accounts
extremely raw and needs a lot of work
it just doesn't really make sense to me
so i might even go deep no i'll do i'll
stay with c minus c
minus and and
the quarterback they drafted played one
game last year because of the pandemic
north dakota state played all of one
game
he's going to sit out ideally all of
this year if it goes according to plan
and of course if the team ends up being
good if they would get back to the super
bowl
how do you not keep jimmy garoppolo
next year and maybe the master plan is
they would they would sell
high at that point they would trade
garoppolo as he enters the final year of
his contract because
it's funny we have such a short memory
in
in
uh the nfl and as we follow it 2019
garoppolo plays every game
not an issue no injury problems at all
2020 he gets a sprained ankle week two
he's you know i think out for 10 of the
16 games oh the guy can't stay healthy
well if he plays the entire year
and they're really good and he does well
the narrative changes completely and
there's going to be somebody i think
who would trade for men whereas now i
don't think there's anyone who would
touch him at 25 million dollars after
what happened last year so
i look i'm i suspect they have a plan
i hope they have a plan but what we've
seen of it what we've heard of it i
agree with you
i i and you know c c minus
i i think that's a fair grade to apply
to whatever the 49ers are doing
whether they know what they're doing or
not how about the rams the rams gave us
the first
big oh wow of 2021
when they made the move both to acquire
matthew stafford and
to unload that horrific jared goff
contract that people were trying to tell
them
two years ago don't do it and they did
it anyway now
not a horrific contract jared goff's a
very good
player and a very good friend of mine so
i uh
what is the courtroom term what do you
say
wait a minute you were the guy you you
were the one who planted the idea
in my brain two years ago that the rams
should be the first team
to say to a quarterback who just
happened to hang around
no we're not gonna we're not gonna give
you a giant contract that was you
yeah no i i still think they should have
done that i think jared would have done
that too that was my point is that
if you're a guy who maybe isn't one of
the best quarterbacks i'm not saying
jared is one of the best quarterbacks
i'm saying
great guy great quarterback still has a
lot he went to a super bowl so
check yourself mike florio uh all i was
saying is that
if i if i were in his shoes or a similar
spot i'd be like hey let me try to take
the right amount of money where we can
just keep building around me
i don't know that i also i'm really just
talking out of my ass right now
in the fact that i'm looking at it from
a perspective of
i'd maybe take a little less money so
that i could have really good players
around me
but in reality i'd probably just take
max money because that's what everyone
really does
and i didn't never respond to anyone for
doing that here's the bottom line
the rams and and i talked to a gm about
this right after the trade happened
you get stafford from the lions and you
send
goff plus two first round picks and a
third round pick
that's your package to get staff and the
gm and i who had the conversation
came to the consensus that the rams got
stafford for a one and a three
and the rams sent a first round pick
with goff a brock osweiler type trade
to get goff's contract off the books
that this is basically brock osweiler
tucked inside another transaction
so stan kroenke doesn't figure out that
the contract that they gave to golf was
so bad they had to give up a first round
pick to get it off the books
that's that's the thinking all right all
right i still think
i'd whatever i think jared's good i
think the the lions i think he'll
have a little resurgence here for the
rams we're talking about the rams here
the rams mia grade for the rams i mean i
think they get like a b
plus or a minus just because they saw
like if you're sean mcvay you have aaron
donald
who and jaylen ramsey and that defense
and what they did last year
and they were they were really good they
were really really good
especially at the end of the year and
you're like hey if i can have my guy
and i think matt stafford's the guy and
i've always i've
i'm on the train of matt stafford future
hall of famer that's how i refer to them
i think that they went and addressed the
one need and that it's kind of chips all
in which they've been chips all in for a
while now because of their salary cap
situation
but i like their off season i think that
it really is
an off season where if you have one
thing you want to do and you accomplish
that one thing and it's bigger than
everything else
i think it it it gets a good grade for
me
yeah well and and they they had that one
thing that they wanted to do
because sean mcveigh got to the point
where he couldn't co-exist with jared
gotham all right enough
john enough with the jared go when did
you get co-opted by jared goff i mean
he's a friend of mine
at least get co-opted by a good
quarterback wow
they see that was out of line out of
line objection
your honor this this man is a terrible
lawyer
hey at least i wear my bias on the
sleeve it's just no it's not dude
blake bortles did blake bortles broker
this friendship is that what can i yeah
blake and i are in a rocky spot right
now because he's on the packers so
we'll see what happens he's not gonna be
for long he's gonna be gone the day that
aaron rodgers shows up
all right you don't have a friend of you
you had to get a dog to get a friend
that's what you're doing right now and
and even that and even then it's
questionable
uh you you know my quote about
friendship i think friendship takes too
much effort it's so much easier to
maintain an enemy
all right indianapolis colts give me a
grade all right so the cults
are weird to me i i would probably go
with
um a b-minus because i do think that
carson wentz
this will be interesting i i think frank
wright can get more out of him
i do think that that you know this will
be new place
there i'm of the belief that if a guy
was as good as he was a few years ago
and people kind of forget it because
they won the super bowl without him
but he was the leading the mvp candidacy
when he got hurt
in that game against the rams a few
years ago i think it's still there
i the reason why i don't give them what
i just said did i give a b-minus
the reason why i wouldn't go higher is i
don't know what they're doing they
didn't really replace their offensive
line
they don't really have a fix with
costanzo retiring and and they brought
in eric fisher who probably won't be
ready
week one uh who's you know a great
career but he's at the tail end of it
they got a backup who's coming into the
starting role
i i think that if you go get carson
wentz
you then need to do everything to make
carson wentz
like elevate him to a level where his
offensive line's great where his weapons
are great i don't think they got all the
way there so
i'm gonna give him a b-minus but even
with costanzo retiring and the question
marks with fisher's health
it's a better offensive line than what
he's had in philadelphia of course
i you know he had nothing around him
last year and that's what was weird well
no last year
it was 2019. that's what made last year
so odd
2019 he literally had nothing down the
stretch
he willed that team to the playoffs by
himself when it was only six teams when
they didn't have the
chicago bears memorial eight and eight
playoff spot they earned one of the six
spots in the nfc
somehow that's what made last year's
fall from grace
so stunning because you think hey hey
well as long as wendt stays healthy
this team's good to go but something
snapped and it made it
the simple explanation may be they
drafted jalen hurts in round two and it
broke his brain
jay glazer essentially reported that
during the season
that that he did not react well to it
and that ended up
being the thing that that destroyed the
relationship and we saw it play out week
after week last season
yeah so i i i don't know
carson wants to say this one's supposed
to be about the eagles but i'm just
trying to make sense of all of it
i just think he's got a good situation
in indianapolis and he needed a fresh
start
and i think for for the colts look at
what they've been trying to do
since andrew luck decided he was done a
couple of years ago
the you know they had philip rivers and
he got him to the playoffs and they gave
the bills everything they could handle
i think carson wentz better car carson
wins better than phillip rivers
i think this is a team that really is a
force potential to be reckoned with i'm
surprised the only game of b
minus all right bump him up to a b let's
go b
all right well because you know what it
is mike you know what it is i i
actually believe that carson wentz can
be good but man was he bad
that sentence put some he's not a friend
he's no no no but
i mean he was so bad he was so bad
and that's more gambling coming out
where i had some games where i was like
why did i do this
why did i have carson wentz he spins no
one likes to spin
for no reason more than carson wentz the
guy just is
addicted to spinning just to waste time
in the pocket
tennessee titans they most recently made
noise with the trade for julio
jones uh they they trying to make the
defense better they're taking a flier
with bud dupree giving him a lot of
money coming off of his acl tear what
offseason grade do you give them
so i i mean i would probably i'm gonna
give him like a b
and and i like the julio jones i'm
surprised more teams weren't in on that
that seemed ridiculous to me um i know
that if he plays well they're gonna have
to give him more money and all that
but that offense is is ready to go i
still just
i don't know what they're doing on
defense i i i think bud dupree
is a guy who was really good in
pittsburgh
really good in pittsburgh but that's
because pittsburgh played to his
strengths
and knew how to use him now he's going
to go to tennessee he's going to be
expecting to
to perform right away the the deal with
the titans last year
it was their defense they had the worst
third down defense in the nfl
they could not get off the field anytime
they got in a big situation it fell
apart
and then you know they lost some
secondary they bring in janoris jenkins
who's on the
wrong side of 30 and they draft killed
uh farley who
is a a top level talent but
isn't he back surgery so back surgery
right in that look i hope he has a great
career i hope he has a long career but
if you're 22 years old and you're 21
years old and you're getting back
surgery
i'm gonna throw up a red flag i think
that's totally fair so
um i just don't know if they did enough
on defense i think their offense will
keep them in a lot of games
and then when we get down to january
football
when they have to get off the field in
third down it might not happen they got
to re-sign will compton that's what they
got to do
and when you look at that division it
really is colts and titans clearly
above the other two without question and
i think whoever
emerges from that uh yeah you could have
a team and we see this all the year
teams get better or worse as the season
goes on you could have
uh one of these two teams culture titans
it really develops into something
special as the season unfolds
confidence creates more confidence and
by the time you get
into the postseason you're you're ready
to try to climb to the top of the
mountain the patriots trying to get back
to the top of the mountain after missing
the playoffs last year with a seven and
nine record
and look even though they were seven and
nine you look at me you think they were
three and 13
with the talent they didn't have they
went out and they were aggressive this
year what grade do you give
from the aggressive acquiring of free
agents to what they did in the draft
give me a grade for the patriots
i think they get like an a minus they
went and got a lot of talent and
obviously they had a lot of cap space
and they're also getting a bunch of guys
back that that opted out
but i like what they did with the with
the uh tight ends
johnny smith and and hunter henry so
they're gonna you know
try to do that the tight end thing that
eventually basically the patriots
and not invented but that was you know
the first iteration of it
so they're gonna get back there they got
some wide receiver talent
i actually would say the only move that
i don't really like and agree with is
bringing back cam newton
because i just he was that bad and it
wasn't like an
injury thing to me he was just bad he
was just he was just
straight up bad so i you know if you're
going to draft a quarterback and you're
also gonna
have a roster that should be able to
compete for a playoff spot
i don't know why i'd waste time having
cam newton be your quarterback for any
amount of weeks
they got him on a really good deal not
as good as last year
last year he showed up in late june they
really like him they like his presence
they like his leadership they regard him
as the perfect guy to follow tom brady
in new england he's got the magnetic
personality he brings the locker room
together
and i think the cova diagnosis last year
messed him up he denied that he had
brain fog
in the aftermath of having coveted but
that thing that came out of the blue
after week three he missed that monday
night game against the chiefs so they
actually gave the chiefs
a pretty good scare with brian hoyer and
jared stidham
but but i i don't think newton was ever
the same after that i think it took him
a while to come out of it and and now
year two in the system year two in the
system i think he's
he's gonna be better than he was last
year the question is how good will he be
and he didn't have any weapons around
him last year
i still just it just doesn't look right
i don't think he's i
i think the the amount of injuries that
he has had
his throwing motion has just looked bad
ever since the shoulder and the foot the
foot was actually
something that that i think affected him
more than people realize if you look at
where he can
throw the ball around the field now and
and what he feels comfortable doing
planting that foot
i so the these stats are skewed though
mike
they played in that game which was a
thriller that sunday night football game
in seattle
remember how bad seattle's defense was
they were historically
bad so that was a shootout that was a
game that got away from them
those stats to me are inflated where
that game
was was again it was the exception not
the rule
to how that season was gonna go i just i
don't know i i think that the patriots
would be hurting themselves if they
if they try if they tried to force cam
newton into
this role for an extended period of time
this year because i just don't i don't
see it
ma you know and again i i feel like i'm
talking out of both sides of my mouth
but i do truly believe this
because i actually think cam newton
might be for my money
the most electric college football
player of all time he won an mvp
he's had a great career i just don't see
it anymore
and look bill belichick won't hesitate
to remove him from the lineup
if he thinks it's in the team's best
interest he did it a couple of times
last year with jared stidham cam newton
takes it i think cam newton
is at a point in his career where he
will do whatever the greatest coach of
all time arguably in any sport tells him
to do
he's not going to get salty he's not
going to pout if he gets removed from a
game
and we'll find out what mack jones has
15 pick
fell to the patriots and uh could get
interesting what did i give him
a minus gaming a minus oh yeah that's
her all right
good draft by me good job by me
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports